hey everybody it's Mike I hope you guys
can hear me okay
and I'll get started here uh 10 o'clock
you know it's Sunday morning not sure if
my microphone was working there for a
second I was going through some last
minute checks okay good everything is uh
working
um and you know I'm gonna try and keep
it pretty simple today you know not like
one of these big long Marathon uh
webinars workshops whatever you want to
call them
um this is Sunday morning so you know
thanks for getting if you're in the US
thanks for waking up early I know a lot
of people like to sleep late and what
I'll be talking about today is the
reversal scalper so um just really quick
I hear I see a video there a question
video a question from uh Yolanda asking
about markers yeah it should be markers
compatible I'll be doing a separate uh
video on that
and sending it out or posting it I don't
want to get into the marketers part
today Bob I did ask my programmer about
your email with Bloodhound he says it
should be compatible but I'll try it out
and test it myself
because he's saying the he should be
marking the plots but um but anyway guys
just to get started you know the
reversal scalper is a new indicator from
ninja from order flows that it works on
ninjatrader 8. so
you know I don't have like a big slide
deck presented you know but you know
just you know your normal disclaimer
just you know go over that now the
reversal scalper basically what we'll be
talking about today is why we created
the reversal scalper sort of talk about
the settings what the trade entry signal
is for those that aren't familiar with
some of my indicators where to place
your stops and you know I'll talk about
some examples and you know sort of take
you through different markets with
different settings now the thing with
the settings is it's not like there's so
many moving parts so many variables
there's basically
um one main setting which is the
reversal strength as well as you know
whether or not you want to use the trade
entry signal so you know the thing to
remember with reversals right because
there's in my opinion there's a few ways
to approach the market right reversals
um you know momentum are the two main
ones that you want to really look for
and the other things that I like about
reversals and momentum and hence this is
called the reversal scalper is because
it allows you to sort of be trading
ideally in the direction of the market
okay and you know and that's important
because even if you're wrong you should
be able to discern that you're wrong
pretty quick okay and most importantly
with reversals which differ from
momentum is
you know everyone always talks about you
know get a get in on the trend as early
as possible the trend is your friend
right but you really want to where to
try and start
right when the market reverses yeah I
mean Trends can start you know after a
long period of sideways activity
and the reversal scalper also does pick
it up sometimes when that's happening
but you know you really want to get into
a trend as soon as possible and often
you know the closer you get to
um you know the turning points in the
market you know when the signs are there
that the market is reversing you'll ask
your cue to really jump into the market
and
one of the things that I like about
reversals I've always liked about
reversals as opposed to things like
breakouts and other forms of trading is
ideally you know you know where you're
going to be placing your stop and you
know it's based on Market structure
right as opposed to a indiscriminate
dollar amount that you're just sort of
taking an average over the last x amount
of Trades and saying yeah you know this
is the range from
um you know the stop and then you sort
of take an average of that and it's very
clear on the chart where you should be
placing your stop and with the reversal
scalper we highlight the bar sort of the
the initial
place where the reverse is taking place
so you could easily see where you should
be
placing your your stop so
I'm gonna pull up the charts
and I'm going to talk about you know
settings trade entry signal stops and
then we'll go into some examples okay so
this is
a footprint chart and I'm going to start
with a footprint chart
but then I'm going to use mainly a
simple Candlestick chart okay because
again not everybody uses footprint
charts but I do want to show it to you
start out with a footprint chart and
just sort of take it from there so this
is um
crude oil
right now this is a one minute chart now
I do realize you know everyone uses
their own chart
Style
their own ways of you know analyzing the
markets okay so me I prefer you know a
one minute chart I also use things like
tick bass charts and
a certain extent range based charts
so you know if if you use your own chart
just bear with me and you can see how
you can use
um the reversal scalper so let me just
open it up now
the reversal scalper it's very simple in
terms of
settings okay so you can see down here
reversal scalper settings so you know
enter to enable it just really quick you
just enter your email address and click
enable if you don't click enable it
won't show up
um there's a trade entry signal which
I'll talk about
and the parameters the offset is how far
above or below the bar you want the
signal to appear the reversal strength
is this is the main one here reversal
strength uh for crude I like to setting
of around two
the base setting is zero
the default setting when you install
reversal scalper I believe is one
um you could have a sound alert if you
like and you know we explain in the user
guide how to change the sound alert you
know if you don't want to use
the default that we have set up now
there's the buy and sell colors those
two different colors okay
this buy and sell color that you see in
the setting is actually the color of
the bar right the signal bar
or I'll say signal bar but rather sort
of the trigger bar that's saying hey you
know what a reversal is starting to take
place here okay and there's an opacity
that you can change it so for example
okay you can see the blue in this bar
is the
this is sort of you know that telling
you that a reversal is taking place just
as this little blue here this
sort of orchid color it's kind of like a
pinkish color it's called Orchid on
ninjatrader
um and there's another one up in here
the reason why we color this is because
that's going to give you
your stop placements okay so you know if
you're getting short in here this
triangle is actually telling you to get
short so you know your stop is going to
be above this this high or below this
low or below this low or above this High
and
you know rather than sit there trying to
just pick some dollar amount or x amount
of ticks you know it's really based on
you know where the market is reversing
from
now
there's triangles right up and down
triangles let's get back to the settings
here real quick
all right so
the up and down triangles are actually
here not at the bottom these are the
plots you can see it's default is set to
five and for this presentation I I
bumped them up to 10 to make it a bit uh
easier to see
and when you see the triangle that's
what's telling you to take the trade
okay now
getting back to
the settings there is a thing in there
that's called the trade entry setup or
trade entry signal rather this one right
here and what that does okay so you can
see the there's a blue triangle down
here at the bottom it's appearing on the
bar after the bar with uh
where the reversal is starting to take
place
and it will print
after this bar is closed okay it's not
going to print immediately because it's
waiting for that confirmation of this
bar to close then it will print here and
if you're not using the trade entry
signal that's your signal to get long
now if you're using the trade entry
signal I'm just going to show you the
difference
trade entry signal
for those of you that are not familiar
with it it's something that I've been
using in all my
most of my indicators over the last
several years which basically tells me
that you know the conditions are met for
the trade
and not only that but I have followed
through order flow that's taking place
in the next bar so by and I use 2 and 2
which means it's got to move by two
ticks over the next two bars okay so you
can see it's turned on here so what that
means is
so earlier
right we saw this blue triangle appear
here
on this bar now it's appearing here so
what's happening is you have your
reversal forming
this bar is confirming the reversal and
this bar is confirming that you have the
price action going in that direction
okay that's why it's appearing here and
as soon as this bar here moves starts to
move two ticks because it's within two
bars here
above the high since it's a bullish
signal if it was bearish would have to
be below then it's going to print okay
and you know you could just see them all
over the place that's why you don't have
signals here or here
okay up here you have your bearish
signal
so here's your bar that's telling you
hey you know what a potential reversal
is taking place
you waiting for some confirmation here
in this bar and then this bar you get
your trade entry signal coming in
right now it's appearing here and it's
actually going to fire off as soon as
the conditions are being met in that bar
okay and again knowing where to place
your stop is above since this is a cell
right you can place your buy stop if
you're short to get out Above This High
see the market did come back up here and
test that high
where you had the reversal signal
appearing okay so again you know we
wanted something that was easy for stop
placements right that's why we colored
those bars so you can see visually you
know where to place it now if you're
using some sort of automated strategy
that you know it's just going to
automatically it has to enter an ATM you
know I would suggest something a little
bit wider because you could always go in
and manually adjust it I mean if you've
got to understand the market that you're
trading so you know if you're trading
say like this is crude oil
you know I don't know maybe you start
out with 20 ticks then once you're into
the trade you can always adjust it to
a closer place on the chart you know
above the high or below the low if you
were getting long hair
and again you know this is why we use
the trade entry signal is to keep out of
Trades like this where it's just not
going anywhere or going here
now so that's you know basically I mean
there's not a whole heck of a lot of
settings that you really need to
work with and then that's my design
excuse me
you know you don't want to have like 20
different settings that you got to
adjust and then you know you're
fine-tuning it all you know no you try
and keep it simple we put everything
into that sort of that reversal strength
is sort of the the combination of all
the parts
so it's a little bit hard sometimes for
people looking at a footprint chart if
you're not used to it so this is a
Candlestick chart okay your normal
Candlestick chart now
with
reversal scalper you don't need to use
tick replay okay but if you're using
something that requires tick replay so
for example oops
right my footprint chart that I use
requires tick replay so whether tick
replay is enabled or disabled
it doesn't matter you can use it either
way with it enabled or disabled but if
you're using it together with you know
other tools that do use tick replay you
can still use it with tick replay I do
have some indicators that it's weird
because
if you use them with tick replay
they won't work for some reason usually
it's the other way around usually it's
things that
work with tick replay obviously won't
work without take replay but I'm
starting to see some tools that
specifically is the opposite right you
have to turn tick replay off now
so this is crude oil so let's just sort
of take a look at some examples with the
different settings that you're going to
sort of run into here all right so
the default setting when you first
install
reversal scalper okay I believe it is
trade industry signal disabled so
reversal scalpels down here so you can
see trade entry is disabled and it's set
at one okay as the reversal strength
something
so this is what it's going to this is
what it will look like
on your charts okay so this is crude oil
again from from Friday with basically
the default okay now
when you're using let's put this over
here and we can sort of make these
changes so
zero is actually the base not one
it starts at zero and if you're having
zero right you're going to get a lot of
signals now I'll be talking about some
markets like the slower moving markets
like bonds Ultra bonds you know you may
want to play around with zero in those
markets because especially if you're
looking at a time-based chart where you
don't get a lot of the movement that you
do see in other markets obviously like
crude or or mes or mnq or ym or even the
currencies or gold so
you know in some of those slower moving
markets yeah you might want to start
your analysis using a reversal strength
of zero okay so this is zero right you
can see all the signals there you know
when you start going up higher in
strength right it's removing you know
some of these signals in here that what
you're seeing a lot earlier right just
go back to zero you can see on the left
hand side of your chart this choppy area
um then you make it one
okay
the next level is two it's a bit higher
gonna peel off you know it's sort of
like an onion skin depending on the
volatility of your Market is what you're
going to want to decide on what you're
going to use in that market now
with the strength I usually you know I
don't use go through every levels I
usually go like one two three five
ten you know if you wanted to you could
probably go uh FIB numbers but you know
five right so this is three here you
know if you go to Five it's just gonna
remove some more again it really depends
on your volatility of the market okay I
mean even if you go to 10 it might
I have a whole heck of a lot of
difference but there is some difference
okay now
let's go back to zero
okay so you see a lot of signals right
and this is the part that frustrates me
sometimes people get a tool
and not just my indicators but I see it
with a lot of people and they don't go
and start to use it and try to
understand sort of the settings on when
you make adjustments
but now the trade entry signal okay so
you have your reversal strength okay so
this is set at base of zero now if I add
the trade entry signal it's also going
to act as a filter it's going to filter
out some of the trades so you've seen
even with the reversal strength set at
its basic level of zero
right with the trade entry signal you've
filtered out a bunch of losing trades
okay just go back right this is
with it disabled right you've seen a lot
of signals and it's just going to give
you a headache looking at trying to
trade all these signals and you don't
want to be trading every signal right
you want to be trading signals where
you have order flow
that's
follow through you know basically
you know you're identifying a reversal
in a sense you also want others to be
coming in as well and identifying
reversals for whatever reason right
maybe they're not following maybe
they're following Moon Tides or
something you know or a time of day you
know there are people that do that right
they look at the time of day and you
know there should be reversal coming in
here now if you add the trade entry
signal it's going to clean up your chart
a bit okay so you can see here it's
you're seeing better trades now again
this is with the reversal strength set
at one which is the base if you start
adjusting the
reversal strength with the trade entry
signal you know you start going up to a
higher strength you're going to see
less signals because now you're sort of
making the requirements for the reversal
A Little Bit Stronger
and
at the same time you're looking for that
follow through order flow so that's
the trade entry signal turned on with
setting at one you know with two it's
going to remove a couple more
do more if you were to set it you know
at five it might even remove you know
one or two more so again depending on
the market that you're trading it's
something that you know you're going to
want to play around with now I'm not
saying you know you do it after the fact
I mean you do your studies you test it
on what you're comfortable with because
you know everybody has different risk
tolerance levels everyone has you know
different chart types that they're going
to be looking at so again this is just a
simple bar chart you know
some guys have been emailing me about
hikanashi recently and you know tell me
how you gotta you got to use this with
hikanashi I'm like okay
I I just I'm gonna say purist I just
keep my charts simple but if you were on
a chart you know like hikanashi
um you know again I would start at sort
of the the same point you know reversal
strength
start at zero you know I I me personally
I like to use a trade entry signal on
just about all normal moving markets if
the Market's kind of quiet you know
slower moving markets like bonds I might
turn it off
but this is how you know this is the let
me get the crosshairs up here
you know the hikanashi with the signals
I mean generally I mean generally
getting the same sort of moves but
obviously you know the way I can
actually calculates a Candlestick chart
is a bit different than
um
you know a normal Candlestick chart and
again that's what that reversal setting
at zero but with the trade entry
enabled so if you disabled it
you know this is what it's going to look
like okay so you're going to see a few
more signals some that weren't so good
look like the trade was starting to
happen here
um and you get some small trades
so small stop-outs there but you know
overall it's helping you find those
reversals I just prefer to use the trade
entry signal
okay so again you know
that's
Friday you know in in the evening
session in the mornings I'll say evening
but you know early morning let me just
go back to a normal one minute chart get
out of here
because again not everyone's going to
use hikanashi charts and
it's going to get uh that's on you know
like for crude oil I like to stay
between two or three
you know you're still getting moves you
know overnight here's a small move here
there's a nice little move down
um you know Friday morning
again you see let me expand this chart
up so
might be a little bit hard let me just
change the opacity the the color here so
it's a point two I'll change it to 0.5
so you can see these colors maybe
hopefully a little bit better but you're
seeing here right this is
sort of your your
start of your bullish reversal right
then it's coming in then it's finally
confirmed here so I talk about knowing
where to place your stop right let's
expand this up move it up so it's a
little bit easier to see
you know this bar here the low of this
bar is where you're going to be placing
your stop right well not on the low but
just on the other side of that low you
see the market came down and tested that
low before going up right it's a nice
move up from you know 20 all the way up
into the 60s but even here
right you have your bullish
signals coming in here you get your Buy
Signal here your stop just goes below
this low of this blue bar
okay you see Market why not actually
pull down test that level came right
down to that level
but you should already be long then
you're seeing more bullish signals come
up
you know basically from that earlier
start of that move
um you know during the European hours
you know there's some potential cells in
here and we're just sort of went
sideways going up
now that's funny because people see this
signal up here and say ah you know this
indicator sucks because it it picked
this High the move and then the market
sold off well okay do understand right
the market had just moved up pretty much
this is a nice move here from you know
60 all the way up to 25 so it's a 60 70
point move already then you're getting a
Buy Signal that's probably not the best
place to be taken a Buy Signal but
whatever
um you know even you get long in here
even so you got long at the high of this
bar at 29 you know the place in your
stop here at 17 you get stopped out okay
fine you get your next sell signal
coming in here you know around 05
this is your where you're placing your
stop up here at 17. so you're getting
short at o5 this is the bar that you're
gonna be placing your stop behind
right up here at 17.
you know the highest 17 so you place in
18 or 19.
and it makes this nice move back down
from you know the o5 back down to you
know the 60 area even down into the 50s
you know this is the signal you'll be
taking up here this triangle not be
looking to take this one
so and then you know sort of on your way
back up again
um so let's take a look at some other
markets
uh whoops
mini doll or mini doll is a nice market
and you know so the question comes up is
you know what's a good Market to trade
you know should you be looking at
in more volatile markets or can you
trade slower moving markets right
volatile markets obviously are some of
these stock indices crude oil
um
e-mini's gold I sort of lumped together
you may use gold in the currencies
or what I call sort of normal markets
and the slow removing markets obviously
are excuse me are the interest rates you
know bonds Ultra bonds
fives tens even the ultra tense Ultra
tens is a is a nice contract to trade
because you do get some nice movements
you know a second here I'm trying to
drink some water real quick
Okay so
this is gold this is no sorry this is a
mini doll I am and again sort of just go
through the settings right
you know when you install it right the
default settings R1
and this is turned off okay and for some
people that might be you know
a bit too a bit too many signals okay so
where's the cash open this is Friday
you got this area of chop basically
going back and forth
hmm
so what I like to do right again if I'm
new to a market
any Market
I'd say start out obviously at the
defaults right you know I'll go to zero
obviously one I think is already too
many signals because you know this is a
market that has nice movement and you
don't want to be setting it too low
right again zero is the base you know I
go one three
I've
ten you don't really need to go above
10.
some guys have experimented with uh in
the 20s but you don't need to go really
above 10.
obviously one's going to give you very a
lot of signals especially on a market
where you're getting you know
a lot of movement up or down in a bar
right so you know I started
zero I'll sort of just walk through it
before I find something comfortable one
starts to look a little bit better right
you can see these signals
coming in but again you know the
thing is you know for some of you guys
you don't want to be
Death By A Thousand Cuts right these
small little moves here
so what you got to do
then you start adding the trade entry
signal right especially important on
some of these more volatile markets so
you can see the difference right trade
entry signal off we've seen these
shorts here
taking place right trade entry signal is
off
when you turn it on it's removing a lot
of that
sort of you know chop if you will
and it's sort of giving you a slightly
better you know entries yeah I mean
there's still times where you're having
some losing trades you'll hear
a little bit here but you're also you're
not getting you know your death by a
Thousand Cuts but at the same time it's
still allowing you to take advantage of
a lot of those moves if you go with
you know slightly higher real reversal
strength say two
right again it's going to remove
a few of your signals go to three it's
going to remove
a few more of your signals
then you should try it also with trade
entry signal on with your base reversal
strength of zero as well
okay
and again for some of you guys it's
still might be too many signals right so
sort of find your your sweet spot me you
know I like on these more volatile
markets
ym mnq crude oil you know a reversal
strength of two or three
you know for me it's just
just much easier right and you know yeah
you know I'm going to take my loss here
you know this one it didn't stop you out
because
right you're getting your signal on this
bar
but your stop is below here so it's just
sort of going sideways right and
you have to have not just a
stop based on risk but also time risk
right so if you're getting long you know
off of this reversal area you're getting
long in here around
326 it does pull back down to 298 and it
just sort of goes sideways on you keeps
going sideways even you're getting some
more bullish signals and it's still not
moving
you gotta cut it right don't wait for it
to stop you out again
you have a signal over here
and it's just not going anywhere you
sort of underwater for a while then
you're thinking oh this is it it's going
to start happening then you get another
bullish signal here oh this is it should
be taking off and it doesn't it just
pulls back test that test your stop area
then you get another signal this time
it's a little bit lower
okay we can't even take out the high of
this signal it's just sort of going
sideways if you have the opportunity to
have a small profit take it
small loss take it rather than
let it come stop you out because you've
had one chance two chance three chance
your stop is still fine because your
stop is below the low of this trigger
bar
right at uh you know around the 98 97
area
and it's not making a move right at some
point you got to say are we going to
make this move or not then it's just not
making that move
okay so you know that's a you know those
are crude oil
why um again your maq that's I treat the
same as those markets now if you're into
sort of a slower moving market like say
bonds
okay
the 30-year contract ZB so let's just go
back to sort of the default settings
okay so this is the default settings on
Friday okay now Friday you did have some
movement in the market but you know just
you know the CPI day obviously you did
have some movements but you know the day
before CPI was kind of kind of quiet you
know I don't say in a range but you know
basically trading between 24 and and o4
and this is the default settings okay of
no trade entry signal and reversal
strength at one if you had the reversal
strength set at
zero you know obviously you're going to
get a few more signals
as expected
right this is on the CPI day and then
this is on
again on on Friday now
with the market like that moves slower
me personally I prefer to I still like
to
let the market sort of take me in okay
now on a solar moving markets if you're
using the trade entry signal
right even with the reversal strength
set at zero
right you're going to get not that many
signals some days might not get any so
you can see there's one cell here
okay that was on Friday CPI day
yeah you had a few buys
one two three
right here this last one turned out to
be a nice Runner
um you know a couple cells that just
reversed on you pretty quick stopped you
out put on that
previous day where it's just a lot of
sideways activity in here here you had
one signal okay that's what the trade
entry signal turned on and reversal
strength set at zero if you had
you know a higher
reversal strength one
right you might even get a bit fewer
signals okay so this one cell
disappeared so you're just left with the
one by the one cell that didn't work and
another buy and on Friday you still have
that sell signal there
even if you went up to a slightly higher
area three
still got your cell signal there
now that one buy that was coming in here
is gone you just have this one by this
one cell so on on these slower moving
markets right on this day you have no
signals you don't want to go too high on
the reversal strength if you're using
the trade entry signal
you know if you're using the trade entry
signal
sorry not using it you know maybe you
want to try to
use a higher reversal strength three or
you know five even
okay so this is five it's not too bad on
a day that's kind of choppy a little bit
back and forth
right on the CPI day
again not too bad you got that major
move there and you're not going to take
this trade right ahead of the CPI anyway
got a little bit of move up a little bit
of a move down again this is on a one
minute chart
and not everybody uses obviously a one
minute chart and then this is
Friday's activity
um
you know their check a high kanashi
chart on this day
um
one minute
so the settings are set at here settings
of uh well you can start with this
turned off you're not going to use a
five you know keep it at zero
um you know
but
you know not too bad
right on this day again that's sideways
day not a whole lot happened I got the
day before on here yeah this is actually
the 10th was the 10th Tuesday I think
so you know yeah not too bad again I
don't want
to start running out thinking hikingashi
is the answer to everything I I just
prefer to use a simple
one minute chart
on these markets now
when you start going into you know other
contracts say
euro currency okay eurofx 6E
and again starting out with
the indicator settings
all right the default well the default
is turned off in one
I mean zero is obviously going to give
you a lot of settings
so this is the setting at
make this chart a little bit easier to
read for you
setting of one
with no trade entry signal to add the
trade entry signal
oops
good luck it does clean it up a little
bit you catch this move down
this one stops you out you catch another
move down
that's with the
setting of one the default setting with
the trade entry signal turned on but if
you're using zero
right now you're seeing some buys come
in here
so it really depends on on what you want
to
use it with right whether you want to
use the trade answer signal now the
thing with the trade entry signal you
don't have to use two and two you could
use say one and one
right meaning it's got to move by one
tick over the next one bar and
you can see there's a few more signals I
know you could use it's got to move
two ticks over the next five bars
right
signals come in
um you know that's the settings
all right it's going to make a
difference so me personally I've just
found in my own trading and testing over
the years two and two is what works best
for me
okay and
again you know everybody uses their
their own
style of chart not everybody uses a one
minute chart you know sometimes people
say well I use a 100 tick chart
okay well
starting out
you know you just start at the base
setting
and you adjust from there so this is the
default setting you know not not too bad
when you're catching some of these major
moves here
um but
you still want to let the market take
you in
that's the best way to trade right is
let the market get you into the trade so
you're catching this High here for that
move there you're catching this move
down you do have a small move here a
little back and forth here
um you know some small moves in between
small profits small losses
but again you could adjust you know the
strength setting
you know start at zero
okay maybe we don't like what you see on
a chart that's showing zero then you
know you just go through and find you
know on the chart type that you're
looking at again because this is a tick
based chart
right again everybody has their own
personal charts you know I see guys that
use
18 18 or 1818 tick charts okay
you still got to make those slight
adjustments based on the chart you're
trading because you know sometimes more
volatile the chart is
is you're going to need to make an
adjustment you can't trade a sort of a
wider ranging chart you know an 1818
tick chart same way you trade 100 tick
chart just as you you're not going to
trade a
use the same settings that you use on a
one minute chart necessarily that you'd
use on a on a 15-minute chart
so there are some you know slight
adjustments but it's not a big
adjustment you're just really all you're
doing is adjusting
the reversal strength right maybe you've
got you know honestly if I was using a
wider let's say wider chart but let's
take a look at something else real quick
like a five minute chart okay
three yeah not too shabby but you know
you always got to start at one at zero
the base okay so this is a five minute
chart so a trade entry signal
turned on
so you can see here right
okay
yeah yeah
it is what it is you know maybe you're
using some guys like to use a
two minute chart
okay so you know every chart is gonna
you're gonna get different
entry points right it's going to look
different you've got to make those minor
adjustments I mean I personally I like
to use a trade entry signal if you're
not using it that's what it's going to
look like
so then you're going to probably want to
adjust maybe the reversal strength clean
it up a bit so this is no trade entry
signal with the reversal strength set at
at three
okay and you cut from this move
you know from 36 and a half 37
all the way up into the 70s right then
you take a trade here you get stopped
out okay fine you just had a nice move
and this one's going to give you a small
stop out right your stops up here at 63
and a half 64. you know you're getting
short around 60 and a half okay you're
stopped out but you're catching the
moves like this up here or this move
down
so again you know it very really depends
on the chart that you're looking at and
again you know it's
not a one size fits all because
different charge types are going to be
more volatile than others
so
let me uh I got some time here I don't
want to go on all day
but I'll take a look at some of these
questions here
all right uh let me just go through here
does it work with ranco charts
no I don't use wrinkle charts and I mean
I don't know honestly I've
honestly I don't like the the default
wrinkle charts that ninjatrader has
no it's not going to work with it yeah
if you're going to use a ring I don't
know I know other people have things
like uni renko that I've looked at
before so there might be some use to it
but you know the normal wrinkle charts
from ninjatrader
I don't really recommend at all or
anything
um Tim it would be nice to have
adjustable size allow you indicator
yeah this one does actually does have an
adjustable size you could adjust the
size of the arrow not in here
right whether the the default is five
okay
which is that you know you can make it
even bigger you go up to 15.
see here so you can see it's you know
much bigger signals
uh
let me see another question
does the triangle indicator print drain
the bar after the bar has closed okay
that's a good question
so depending on how you're using it okay
this one here is without the trade entry
signal so it would it will appear once
the second bar closes okay once it's
confirmed that you know there's a
potential reversal taking place
it will print as soon as this bar closes
after the bar that's colored it's not
going to print on that bar
now if you're using the trade entry
signal see because it's waiting for that
bar to close before it's it's confirming
it
you know we went back and forth you know
should we print it on the very next bar
or should we keep it on that bar as soon
as it closes because it'll print but
once it's closed now if you're using the
trade entry signal there's a slight
difference here so let me just uh make
an adjustment here
whoops
let me see let me go in here so we could
do let's make that zero
two
okay so for example
let's go here right you can see the
signals it will appear after
as soon as you get your signal bar you
know sort of your your colored bar
this bar is closing and then starting to
move in this bar it'll appear as soon as
it starts it's
correct movement okay so it will print
there as soon as it happens and once
that prints when you're using the trade
entry signal it's not going to reprint
just as
on the other side if you're not using
the trade entry signal
right it will print
as soon as the bar closes so it
eliminates the whole reprint thing
[Music]
um
markers yeah I'm going to do something
on on markers later not today because
it's uh there's just not a lot of time
here so
thick yes it's being recorded
foreign take a look I haven't seen any
of your emails but I'll take a look on
that
you've asked a question you call this a
scalper what type of
what type of targets are you looking at
okay so again you know
I trade order flow right that's how I
trade and I use a footprint chart when I
trade so what I'm looking for is signs
in the order flow that things are
changing now
everybody has their own way of trading
right up you know me I'm an order flow
person I've always been an order flow
person and
I like to read what's happening in the
order flow so if I'm getting something
contradictory in here
okay
so you can see you know here's a trade
okay you're getting short my stops up
here
not really seeing anything too bullish
unless obviously we come up here and
stop me out but it's just sort of going
sideways it's testing this high it's
testing the high of the day starts
coming off then
you know when I see it coming down in
here I see a potential reversal now I
have a lot of the things on my footprint
chart turned off but I do know this is a
bullish Prominent Point of control
um
coming in here after a nice move down to
me that would be a potential sign to get
out of the trade
you know and just reading other things
that's happening
in the order flow so it really depends
you know again I'm not a huge I'm you
know people are trying to twist my arm
to get more into automated trading sort
of trading robots Etc I know I'm sure I
don't say I'm moving in that direction
but I'm going there kicking and
screaming because I like to read what's
happening in the market and you know
once you sort of go in with automated
systems and and trading robots
it really
you know you got to sort of be precise
on your your entries and I'll show you
on your exits you know like
this is where I Gotta Get out no matter
what right because you know what you
could be looking at is
you know every trade whether you like to
admit it or not starts out as
you know a potential scalp
and it's from there that you know once
you're reading what's happening in the
market can you continue
going in that direction or is there
something that's coming into the market
that's saying the opposite saying hey
you know what you should be getting out
of this trade you know and it could just
be another signal coming in or it could
be something in the order flow or it
could be you know what other
indicator that you're using right
because again you know I do know you
know everybody sort of has their own
indicators that they use
that they rely on to help them you know
find you know areas where they should be
getting out you know some people I don't
like to use bib levels to get out right
or fit extensions things like that you
know the golden ratio so it really
depends
on what you're using
foreign
[Music]
asking about uh the e-minis so
many chart
whoops
give it a second to come up here
okay so this is e-mini's now you know
again I sent out a bunch of charts over
the week of the e-minis
you know here's some bullish signals as
the market is moving up not really
seeing any bearish coming in
you know there was one bearish signal
over here near this High
you know it was a bear signal coming in
this is what's the settings I'm using on
this one this is just
the trade actually signal
setting up two okay so it's a little bit
strong
okay so you got to buy Here Sell Here
I hear again me personally I don't
really like to sit through trades for
hours because I'm a day trader I trade
intraday I'm reading what's happening in
the Oracle because I know that
especially now the way the markets trade
you know
things change right they come and go
right I mean orders are coming you know
people's perception and we're living in
this
Information Age where information is
just coming out like a fire hose
you know over the Internet over
Bloomberg over TV that everyone is is
their ideas are changing really quick
right so again
the way these markets are you know
there's a lot of opportunity day in day
out that you know you don't necessarily
need to be holding onto a trade all day
long
okay
so again there's some potential signals
here but there was no trade actually
you're looking for the triangle here
right you get it on this that'll move up
here from you know the 93 all the way up
into the 99s you know
this one at nine o'clock you know you
just be careful anytime you got a number
coming out you know the 8 30 and the
nine o'clock times
[Music]
um
you know 7 30. 8 30 is when the cash
opened but 7 30 you know when these
numbers come out
this one didn't work
there was a short in here again you know
all you also you always got to be taking
you know this guy he's commenting in the
comments about
stuff but uh
Market structure right just understand
you know you're short you're getting
short going into a low can the market go
lower yeah it can as you can see here if
you took the signal yeah the market
dropped off from you know 90s down into
the 70s but
you gotta always be one you know is
there that capacity for that market to
move like that
Okay so
yeah this is five in the morning
you know this is the overnight session
so yeah that's the e-minis
that is the
ES
one minute chart
and again you know the settings on that
is just
straight out your signal on with a
strength of two
um Bob it says
okay Bob
I was going to make a note of that Bob
whenever do you alter offset parameter
and you'll well all the offset parameter
does
let me just get back here to
well let's go back to a simple
bar chart
well default is set at one if you were
to change it to five right it just moves
it up so you know because sometimes
people have other indicators that are
also
signaling with a triangle or something
else and if you have it
depending on where it is it might
overlap right so what that does so you
can see right like up here
further off the bar or further below the
bar that's
if you're going to adjust if you got
nothing else going on it right you just
keep it at one you know closer to the
bar
but if you got something else that
you're used to using you know maybe you
want to set it at two or three a little
bit above just so it doesn't overlap it
Edward OS yeah it can run on
charts with other indicators
um Neil asks is straight entry signal
available for your other indication yeah
it is available for most of the other
indicators
see here can you
explain the validity bar okay that
validity bar is the bar that's colored
blue or this Orchid color okay and
that's sort of where it's the reversal
is starting and then when you add in you
know the strength and the trade entry
signal
is taking other things into account to
sort of confirm that the reversal is
actually taking place
okay
but that
is the validity bar as you call it you
know that's the bar that if that bar
gets violated
meaning if a trade you know for a
bullish signal if it trades below it
then you're gonna you you want to get
out of the trade immediately or if it
trades above the bearish one that's your
point to get out right that's your stop
placement area that's why we call it
that validity bar
Richard has no it doesn't repaint I
thought I was I was clear on that it
won't repaint once it paints there
because if you're using the trade entry
signal as soon as it makes that move
it's going to print and it won't repaint
if you're not using the trade entry
signal
once the bar after that validity bar
confirms it and closes it the bar closes
then it will paint and it's going to
paint on that second bar
but it's going to paint it after that
bar closes
yeah Alan you you could use it on
multiple computers you don't need to add
extra computers for the reversal scalper
you'll need extra the extra license
let me see here
Okay so Richard does the blue color at
10 48
there's
I'm not sure what you're asking here
maybe that's a different chart
is it this other Church
um then the blue arrow at 1051 paint at
the end of the bar so
this bar the blue bar will paint
but once that bar closes you
remember it's not just having the
validity bar painted a color
right for a signal to happen you still
need some other confirmation this is
just sort of clueing you in
that hey you know what a potential
reversal might be taking place it's when
the triangle prints that's the actual
signal that you're taking you're not
taking the signal off of the color of
the bar
okay it's just a visual thing because
you know you want to be knowing where
these reversals are taking place but
then you still want the confirmation if
you don't
want to use
these colors all right yes you can just
change it to
either transparent
right well now you're not going to
change it transparent but um
what you would do then is
let's go back to
whatever it was a navy and uh
let's make it orchid
I guess you'd make it very faint zero or
but
again you don't have to use those I mean
you can just keep them your normal bar
colors the green
and reds at the bottom
all right well you gotta get one
right just so you're not confused with
that so
again it's up to you whether you want to
use it I like to use it because it's
going to give me a visual on where to
place my stop
I don't want to be struggling in placing
a stop way up here at the swing high
when I could be placing my stop based
off of
you know where the reversal is
potentially taking place in the market
there's a time frame differ according to
instrument
is so high you know which to use
well again you know you just want to use
it try it with your chart right the
chart that you're using for trading
and
it's one of those things where again you
know
every I can talk to 10 Traders
and I get
and ask the same question what chart do
you use and I could get literally 10
different answers so you know it really
depends on on the chart that you're
using and your adjustments now
just a little more s what about
uh well Greg really quick no Delta
is not part of it
does
the scalp will work on 10 range bars
Okay so
let me just uh go back here
remove it real quick edit again
Scholars are set up
um
and again once you first time you enter
your email in there and click enable you
don't have to go in and re-enter it but
if you're adding it fresh again you will
have to click enable but it already
registers your email
um
with range-based charts okay let me just
go in here real quick
let's make this a little bit bigger to
see
there's a 10.
okay so go to Range based charts here
and range charts what am I looking I'm
looking at euro currency
with a range based chart
especially a 10 range chart
it can get a bit tricky honestly is
because
on volatile markets 10 range might not
be enough
Okay so
for example right I have trade entry
signal turned on
if I turn it off
and use the default setting of one
you're going to see a lot of signals
right it's not going to be effective at
all because what you're getting is a lot
of potential reversals up and down
because it's just upticking by you know
again this is Euro currency let's go
change the market to ES
right and it looks like crap on an ES
10 range chart
with the default settings right so you
probably need to go in and adjust
probably either you'd want to put on for
one through trade entry signal okay
and you'd probably want to use some sort
of strength you know
I don't know three this is three
okay but again even with the 10 range
e-mini chart
last thing you want if you're using a
range based chart really the whole point
of using a range based chart is seeing
how the market is moving
not related to time and if you're using
a 10 range chart on ES sort of one of
the the signs of
sideways Market or maybe your the 10
range is
sort of two two I don't say small
to take in the price movements is a lot
of back and forth green bar Red Bar
Green Bar Red Bar Green Bar red bar
right like that
it's not really necessarily giving you
that move because you're sort of ticking
up ticking down ticking up ticking down
um you know you might want to use
I don't want to you know make you change
the chart type that you're using but if
you're using say you know a 15 range
chart
you know you're now you're starting to
get more of the
price movements per se okay
then you know again if you were using
something like
not the trade entry signal
you know maybe you want to use a higher
strength go from there sort of set it
out but again on these markets that
you're going to get a lot of sideways
activity on
you're going to get chopped up you know
regardless of what you're using you can
see the day before when you're getting
nice movements in the market you're
getting some nice trades again this is
the problem with using range-based
charts is it sort of ticks up ticks down
picks up ticks down takes up ticks down
Red Bar Green Bar Red Bar Green Bar Red
Bar Green Bar
right what you know maybe you'd probably
want to try is
I'm not asking you to change your chart
type by any means but
you know if you're on
a different chart right a high kenoshi
chart for example okay
that's well let's set it at zero
okay
I'm gonna give you
better swings to deal with so again it
really depends on on the chart type that
you're using so anyway guys I'm going to
end it there for today we got on for
about an hour I got through a lot of
these questions so that was good I'll
take a look and uh you know I'll send an
email out if there's any of these late
questions coming up
some I did explain the validity bar okay
that's the bar that's the colored bar
where it's picking up what's happening
in the order flow
um for the reversal so for example
[Music]
okay this bar here right the bar that's
colored that's the validity bar this bar
that's colored is the wood U Bar this
bar that's again
if it might be a little bit hard to see
with the collar so I'll just make it a
little bit stronger
the Orchid and the navy colors that's
the validity bar
that's telling you that hey you know
what a reversal is starting here
okay based off of you know what it's
analyzing
in the order flow that's been happening
right validity bar here
at the Liberty bar here just as the
bearish one up here
right the bearish one here and the
signal the trade signal is the triangle
up or the triangle down for shorts the
triangle up for longs
the validity bar is the area that you're
going to place your stop behind so if
you're long
right you're getting long it's this low
of this bar you came back stopped you
out then made the run but this bar here
right this is the ability bar
top just goes right below it when I
catch that move just like here this is
the validity bar you're going to place
your
stop if you're getting long hair you're
gonna place your stop to get out just
below
so that's what the validity part does
all right so anyway guys you know Bob
I'm still investigating that
Bloodhound issue
um send me some more notes that'll be
helpful at least I could go back to my
programmer on it but um I'm still
investigating it so you know the I'll
probably be later this week I'll be
doing something
try to get a uh something with Pablo
sort of pinned on a date that we could
do something together
um on some of the order flow tools so
I'm gonna send out one you know I get
some time this week on on markers as
well so thanks everyone
and uh enjoy the rest of your Sunday and
you know again you know the reversal
scalper for now it's
at about half his normal price because
once this promo period goes over you
know I usually I'll launch my indicators
and the first week or so you know I do
offer a discount but after that
you know price you know it sort of goes
on the Shelf at the normal price so
let's just uh go to reversalscalper.com
and you can learn more about it so
thanks again for taking your time out
everybody enjoy the rest of your Sunday
the rest of your weekend it's a long
weekend here in the US so thanks
everyone bye-bye